tom is in san antonio hey tom how are
you
good thank you dave uh i had a question
about
um a property that i sold a year ago
um we had an agreement they made a
10-year
loan and i'm financing it for them but
we had an agreement that
they would be able to pay it off after
two years um
they've paid up to exactly one year so
far and i just want to know now they're
wanting to pay it all off
and if they paid it all off now i think
the interest i would lose would be about
45 000
and i'm wondering if i should go ahead
and take the money and invest it or
stick out for the next year
wow so you're charging what kind of
interest rate
six and a half percent wow
okay and so this is like uh 800 000
loan um the actual
loan amount was 708 yeah 750. so about
709.
okay so 45 thousand dollars the interest
for one year at six and a half
but they've gotten been able to get a
loan better than six and a half
well they wanted to they wanted to pay
it off sooner anyway and
my attorney uh decided it would be
beneficial if we say we'll even pay it
off early but not
until at least two years and they agreed
to that
okay so i don't know if they're getting
a loan somewhere else here they've just
got the money
okay it's a commercial property and uh
the
that when when i owned it the occupants
were paying eight thousand dollars a
month ran
and they're the people who bought it
their payment to me is about 4 700
a month they've gotten another loan
okay um just took them a while to get a
bank
ah
i didn't even think of that but i guess
that would make sense with six and a
half percent interest they probably got
a much better interest rate
yeah i wouldn't take much um in a three
percent world
um
trying to think what i would do if i
found myself in this case okay here's
your down here here's what's running
through my head i'll just go ahead and
say it all out loud so you can kind of
calculate it with me tom okay
um sure number one there's the forty
five thousand dollars that you would
have gotten
had they taken it all the way through
two years uh what's the
how much did they put down they put down
uh the selling price was
okay so you've got a loan almost equal
you've got a loan very close to equal to
what the property's
worth right so you don't want this
property back
no no the main reason i sold is because
it's
in el paso and i'm 550 miles away i'm
telling you you don't want it back i
mean if they had put down 200
000 and you could take it back for 500
and do it again
you'd do i'd take that right but you
don't have equity here
you're not going you know so they're not
threatening
to hand you the keys but i'm just saying
uh that that kind of tells me how much
hardball you want to play
not much because you don't want this
thing back we want to work this out
okay so what i would do is say um
i was supposed to get another 45 000 out
of you guys
in interest um i will let you pay it off
early and negotiate a prepayment
penalty that is not 45 000
but less i thought about that and i was
thinking maybe
throw up maybe half exactly what i had
in my 25
i might even say 20. say if you you know
if you'll pay me half of what you were
going to pay me
they're probably if they're getting
three percent that's still
uh it doesn't really save me money
doesn't save money close enough though
i mean 15 to 20 if you could get the
information out of them in the
discussion as to what they're doing
and what their interest rate is then it
would tell you how much it's going to
save them
like if they got a two percent then
they'd save four and a half you can
calculate out
don't take the whole four and a half but
take a chunk of it right
but if they're getting if they're
getting a four percent and they're two
and a half
and you're offering and the savings
you're offering them is equal to three
they're not going to do that
i don't know how i'd find that that
information i would ask
yeah you think they would just tell me
yeah i just say why are you paying it
off
oh you got another loan call what was
the rate you got on the new loan i'm
glad you were able to get a better rate
because i want to work this out with you
i don't want to charge you the whole
interest as a prepayment i want to let
you go and i'd love to have my money i
got some other stuff i can do with it
but let's work this out for a win-win
where we kind of meet in the middle
okay and don't charge them don't charge
them a penalty that is greater than
their savings
right there you go right i get it
then okay so if we come to an agreement
then i should probably have my attorney
drop
the thing i'm yeah it should be a
one-page thing
it's a release it's really a release
provision i agree to release the thing
and i'll give you a deed release on this
i'll release and cancel the note
for a payment of x plus x penalty
the actual principal balance plus a
penalty of 21 000 or a penalty of 17 000
or whatever you come to agreement to
right
yeah that seems fair yeah
they're getting out and you're not
you're not going to take all of it
um because i bet you they're not saving
45 000
by the way by doing this a year early
they're thinking that you're just gonna
go hey i want my money
which most people do by the way um so
nothing wrong with what you're doing
i'm trying to take a little a little
tougher stand
uh just because it sounds like they have
a real reason to do this but there's
nothing wrong with asking
i just like having a great conversation
because if i get information i can
design a deal
that's good for them and good for me
right
i see i'm not trying to screw them i'm
just trying to design something because
if i was trying to screw them i would
just go 45 000 bucks right because
and they're not going to pay you off
then they're going to sit there another
year
because they're not i'm guaranteeing you
they didn't get a rate low enough on a
commercial building of 700 000
loan cheap enough that they're saving 50
cents on the dollar here now dave let me
ask you this question
would it be a bad idea let's say if they
come back say yeah we got an interest
rate for three and a half percent
would it be bad to just renegotiate the
contract with him and say all right i'll
go down to three percent
don't you all sign up at least five they
need i'd let them go and get their new
loan
because they might lose the loan over
the coming year or they might
the rates might tick up over the coming
year it could change the deal
but that wouldn't be a bad thing either
if it was a longer than one year
yeah i might consider just lowering my
rate if you want to be in the mortgage
business now that's the other side tom
of this discussion okay is if you
push this and you end up with this
property back
that's a bad thing okay okay uh that's
why i don't carry notes back when i sell
property i will sell a property cheaper
as long as i get all my money yeah then
if i carry a note back
the only way i want to carry a note back
is what we used to call in the business
happy happy loans
okay and a happy happy loan is you get a
good enough interest rate
and you which he did he got a great
interest six and a half in this market
is a
booming interest rate right absolutely
um and you get enough of a down payment
that you're happy if they pay because
you love the interest rate and you're
happy if they don't pay
because you're happy to take the
property back yep and so if you put 200
000
down on this deal and i'm getting it
back for 500 it's worth 750 i i'm not
mad about taking it back
because i can make money on the on the
flip again yeah but uh
he's not got any margin on taking it
back because he didn't get enough of a
down payment i like it now here's
another question dave and i'm asking
because i'm learning
i'm learning going to on the ramsay show
um
and charge it to my head if i ask the
wrong question i'm asking the learning
i'm debt free got my money you know all
that and if i go out there and do
something like
that and charge someone interest do you
suggest that people know that or not no
i would not do that
because i think you can take that cash
and make more than six and a half on it
i got you
either by buying more real estate you
make a better rate of return than that
if you're careful
yeah and or investing in good mutual
funds you can make a better rate of
return
than that if you're careful there you go
i thought so and so
and uh while that property is going up
in value
your notes not changing it's actually
going down
so you're better off if you're going to
collect payments off a building
you're better off to collect rent and be
the owner yes then you are collect
payments off a note
uh and so uh but but if you're going to
carry a note then get a good
high interest rate and get a good strong
down payment happy happy loan
happy on both ends but i don't recommend
that that's why i don't carry it yeah
cause i figure if i'm gonna sit here and
worry about whether somebody's gonna pay
me monthly
yeah i'm gonna worry about the renter
while this thing's going up in value
right and i get the upside yeah so you
don't get any upside once you step out
or the ownership role and become the
bank
gossip i just wanted to ask it's a good
question it's a good discussion
and um it's something to think through
there's this is a
that's an unusual question in these
times because interest rates are so low
very few people
carry back owner terms in this situation